Hallo, guten Tag. Mein Name ist Ekrem Özbüller. Ich bin auf dieser Station als Assistent als
Tätig. Ich würde gerne heute mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch durchführen. Alles
in Ordnung. Am Anfang benötige ich ein paar persönliche Daten, dann können wir
weiterführen. Wie heißen Sie? Ich heiße Tim Yelcht. Könnten Sie bitte Vor- und Nachnamen
beschreiben? Ja, ich nenne ihn Tim. Mein Nachname ist sich Jels Cezar. C ist Cezar.
Cezar. Ja, C. H und am Ende T. Teodor. Ja, wie Teodor. Danke. Herr Yelcht. Ja. Herr Yelcht, wie alt sind Sie? Ich bin 38 Jahre alt.
38 Jahre alt. Wann sind Sie genau geboren? Am 8.4.1986. 18.4.1986. Ja, genau. Wenn ich richtig
verstanden habe. Danke Ihnen. Herr Yelcht, wie groß sind Sie? Herr Doktor, ich bin 1,73 Meter groß. Und wie viel wiegen Sie, Herr Yelcht?
Herr Doktor, ich wiege 80 Kilo. 80 Kilo? Ja, seit 80 Kilo. Herr Yelcht, was für Sie zu uns? Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen? Herr Doktor, mir geht es nicht gut. Ich habe Hüsten.
Ich habe Hüsten. Seit wann haben Sie Hüsten? Ich habe seit 6 Tagen Hüsten. Mit gelblichem und grünem Auswurf. Aber ohne Blut. Es gibt kein Blut.
Ohne Blut. Aber seit 6 Tagen gelblich und mit gelblich und grünem Auswurf. Aber ohne Blut. Ja.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihre Hüsten beschreiben? Wie stark, leicht oder schwer? Wie würden Sie beschreiben, Ihre Hüsten?
Das ist natürlich schwer. Weil es schwer für mich ist, bin ich jetzt hier. Wie kann ich beschreiben? Könnten Sie das beschreiben?
Vielleicht haben Sie Schmerzen beim Hüsten? Ich habe auch Begleitung, Luftnot und Schmerzen, Herr Doktor.
Ich habe Luftnot und Schmerzen. Ja, seit 3 Tagen habe ich Luftnot, Herr Doktor. Ich verstehe. Wie ist die Schmerzen? Stechend, brennend, sechend, dumpf?
Ich habe Brustschmerzen, Herr Doktor, seit 3 Tagen. Gibt es noch? Sie sind ziehend und stechend. Ziehend und stechend.
Die Schmerzen waren dauerhaft oder phasenweise? Jetzt dauerhaft, Herr Doktor. Jetzt dauerhaft. Und?
Und im Laufe der Zeit sind sie schlimmer geworden. Aber am Anfang langsam aufgetreten.
Am Anfang langsam aufgetreten, dann nachher schlimmer geworden. Und die Husten auch dauerhaft oder phasenweise? Zum Beispiel morgen oder abend?
Vielleicht morgen ist es häufiger als tagsüber, aber ich habe nicht mehr einen Unterschied zwischen Tageseit und Tageseit. Aber morgen ist es vielleicht häufiger.
Aber ich habe nicht immer Husten. Natürlich phasenweise. Nicht dauerhaft. Herr Jasch, rauchen Sie? Nein, ich rauche nie, Herr Doktor.
Keine. Sie sind nicht Raucher. Alles gut. Ok. Herr Jasch, was machen Sie vom Berufli? Ich bin Tischlermeister, Herr Doktor. Tischlermeister. Ok.
Herr Jasch, gibt es eine Auslöse für die Husten? Haben Sie etwas bemerkt? Was für eine Auslöse? Hausstaub oder Feuchtigkeit?
Herr Doktor, wie gesagt arbeite ich seit Jahren als Tischlermeister. Natürlich mit Holzstaub. Aber das habe ich nicht bemerkt. Etwas Ungewöhnliches habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Haben Sie in der Leistung 55 Jahre bekommen?
In der Leistung 3 Monate. Alles gut. Herr Jasch, gibt es etwas, das die Schmerzen sich verschlechtert oder lindert?
Herr Doktor, wenn ich sitze oder stehe, ist das besser. Aber im Leben Schlimmer. Ok.
Herr Jasch, strahlen Sie die Schmerzen irgendwo aus? Was meinen Sie? Strahlung? Zum Beispiel in den Rücken oder Bauch. Nein, eigentlich nicht. In den Hals.
Herr Jasch, wie schwer sind die Schmerzen? Würden Sie mir mal beschreiben auf eine Schmerzkala? 0 ist kein Schmerz, wobei 10 sehr starkes Schmerz. Wie beschreiben Sie?
Ich würde sagen, es waren 6 von 10. Herr Doktor. 6 von 10. Herr Jasch, ich verstehe nicht. Sie haben aktuell sehr starkes Schmerz.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es sehr stark ist oder sehr stark. Aber nach Ihrer Schala würde ich sagen 6.
Ich möchte sagen, möchten Sie eine Schmerzmittel oder brauchen Sie etwas?
Jetzt brauche ich nicht, aber ich möchte eine, nicht eine vorübergehende Lösung.
Sie können bis zum Ende weiterführen. Wenn Sie sehr starke Schmerzen oder Luft- oder Atemnot haben, sagen Sie mir einfach.
Ok. Herr Doktor. Ja, wieso mein Hüsten?
Ich kann Ihnen dabei helfen. Herr Jasch, haben Sie Fieber oder Schnellfrust?
Herr Doktor, ich habe Fieber. Gestern habe ich das gemessen. Es war 38,7 Grad. Mit Schnellfrust auch.
Und noch stark gesagt, seit wann haben Sie Fieber oder Schnellfrust? Ungefähr?
Seit gestern kann ich sagen. Seit gestern. Herr Jasch, Sie haben schon gesagt, Sie haben noch eine Atemnot. Seit wann haben Sie die Atemnot?
Ja, wie gesagt, habe ich seit drei Tagen die Atemnot.
Drei Tage die Atemnot. Haben Sie Herzrasen, Herzschlag?
Herr Doktor, seit sechs Tagen, nein, Entschuldigung. Nein, das ist ja nicht Herr Doktor.
Ist Ihnen schwindelig oder haben Sie Kopfschmerzen? Auch dabei?
Nein, ich habe keine solche Schmerzen.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Probleme beim Stuhlgang?
Das habe ich nicht. Nein.
Und Wasserlassen? Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen? Nein.
Schlafen Sie in der Nacht gut? Haben Sie eine Schlafstörung durch oder Einschlagung?
Herr Doktor, ich schlafe schlecht wegen der Schmerzen.
Wegen der Schmerzen, Schlafstörung. Seit wann haben Sie diese Schlafstörung?
Weil ich seit drei Tagen Schmerzen habe. Seit drei Tagen, Herr Doktor.
Drei Tage, alles gut. Herr Jaesch, ich würde gerne fragen,
haben Sie schon wegen dieser Beschwerden Ihrem Hausarzt schon besucht oder ist das das erste Mal?
Seit sechs Tagen ist das zum ersten Mal, Herr Doktor.
Haben Sie Ihren Hausarzt besucht für diese Beschwerden?
Nein, wie gesagt, diese Beschwerden habe ich seit sechs Tagen.
Und inzwischen habe ich keine Besuch zu meinem Hausarzt.
Ja, okay.
Herr Jaesch, haben Sie einen Test zu Hause gemacht oder vielleicht zum Beispiel einen Kohlentest?
Ja, ich habe Schnelltest gemacht und war negativ.
Was war negativ?
Herr Doktor, vielleicht möchten Sie wissen, meine Tochter hatte letzte Woche so etwas Endliches.
Ja, natürlich.
Bei ihr wurde Braun-Schittes-Diagnose festgestellt.
Ja, bei Ihrer Tochter. Gut zu wissen. Danke für die Information, Herr Jaesch.
Okay, ich notiere meine Tochter, erste Beschwerden vor einer Woche, haben Sie gesagt.
Kann das sein, dass ich von meiner Tochter diese Krankheit bekommen habe?
Ja, natürlich. Kann sein, als theoretisch ist das möglich.
Haben Sie jedes Jahr eine Vorerkrankung? Zum Beispiel eine Bluthochdruck oder eine andere Krankheit?
Seit drei Jahren habe ich Bluthochdruck, Herr Doktor.
Bluthochdruck seit drei Jahren. Nehmen Sie dagegen einen Medikament ein?
Ja, dagegen nehme ich Ramiplil. Einmal täglich. Morgen oder Abend?
Morgens.
Gibt es noch etwas?
Nein.
Ich denke, Sie wissen.
Meinen Sie gegen Bluthochdruck?
Nein, nein. Gibt es noch etwas andere Krankheit?
Andere Krankheit? Nein.
Okay.
Kann das sein?
Sehr gut.
Herr Jaesch, würden Sie schon mal operieren?
Ja, mit elf Monaten wegen eines Leistungsboden.
Mit elf?
Ja, mit elf Monaten.
Elf Monate?
Ja, als ich Baby war.
Ja, ich verstehe. Elf Monate. Sehr früh.
Herr Doktor, warum war das eigentlich notwendig, wenn man so klein ist?
Leift Monate ist zu früh, ich denke.
Ja, ich verstehe. Aber das ist sehr wichtig.
Es sollte deswegen so früh sein, weil normalerweise vor der Geburt bei den Hoden war der Bauch.
Aber nach der Geburt, spätestens bis zwei Monate, sollten beide Hoden in den Hodensack bleiben.
Oh, das klingt interessant.
In der ersten, im ersten Jahr, beide Hoden oder eine Hode im Bauch oder in der Leiste, ist das gefährlich sein.
Gefährlich sein könnte.
Was meinen Sie mit gefährlich?
Ja, es gibt ein paar Risiken wegen eines Leistungsboden oder im Bauch Hoden.
Es gibt ein paar Risiken, weil es zu spät ist und die Unfluchtbarkeit oder die Umdrehung ist.
Okay, klar.
Es sollte früh sein.
Und?
Als ich 15 Jahre alt war, hatte ich eine Gelingtarmenschwernung, Herr Doktor.
15 Jahre?
Ja.
Gut. Herr Jast, haben Sie schon gesagt, Sie sind Nichtraucher?
Ja, ich trinke nur Alkohol.
Wie oft?
Alkohol trinke ich, aber sehr wenig. Ein Glas Wein prog.
Super.
Kurz zu hören.
Weil es für meine Gesundheit nützlich ist, trinke ich.
Wein oder?
Es würde empfohlen, ich habe immer gehört, ein Glas Wein oder zwei Glas Wein pro Woche für die Gesundheit nützlich ist.
Ja, ähnliche Nachrichten habe ich so viel gehört, aber ich bin ein Mediziner, deswegen kann ich nicht Wein oder einen alkoholischen Getränk empfehlen.
Weiter nicht.
Und haben Sie Allergie, Herr Jast?
Ja, ich bin gegen Novalgen allergisch.
Okay. Wie reagieren Sie sich gegen Novalgen?
Wenn ich Novalgen nehme, habe ich ein enger Gefühl.
Enge Gefühl?
Okay. Herr Jast, leben Sie noch?
Ja, Entschuldigung, nein. Mein Vater ist verstorben an Lungenkarzinom.
Es tut mir leid. Lungenkarzinom.
Aber Gott sei Dank lebt meine Mutter noch. Aber sie hat auch manche Probleme. Sie leidet an Schütterleumung, Herr Doktor.
Schütterleumung.
Was sind die Ursachen dafür?
Ja, leider für Schütterleumung haben wir keine festen Weisen.
Es gibt viele verschiedene Risikofaktoren, aber bestimmte Gründe sind leider nicht bekannt.
Deswegen ist Alter ein Risikofaktor. Wir werden noch weiter recherchieren.
Herr Doktor, mein Opa ist auch an Lungenkrebs verstorben. Habe ich auch Lungenkrebs wie mein Vater und mein Opa? Ist das erblich?
Ja, natürlich. Lungenkrebs könnte erblich sein. Aber das ist nur eine mögliche Weise.
Gibt es eine, wie soll ich sagen, ja, das könnte sein. Aber ich denke so nicht.
Was hat mich veränglückt gemacht, Herr Doktor?
Nein, nein, nein. Lungenkrebs könnte erblich sein. Aber es gibt viele verschiedene Symptome.
Vielleicht haben Sie bei Ihrem Sputum Blut bemerkt. Sie haben schon gesagt, ohne Blut. Verstehen Sie mich? Was ich meine?
Ich bin davon nicht ganz überzeugt. Aber Sie sind erst.
Sollen wir das Gespräch zum Ende führen? Dann können wir wieder über dieses Thema sprechen.
Herr Just, was machen Sie beruflich?
Wie gesagt, bin ich Tischlermeister. Kann ich Krankenschreibung bekommen, Herr Doktor? Seit drei Tagen kann ich nicht arbeiten.
Wegen dieser Krankheit kann ich nicht zur Arbeit gehen.
Ja, ich verstehe. Herr Just, sind Sie verheiratet?
Aber Herr Doktor, ich brauche die Antwort dieser Fragen. Kann ich Krankschreiben bekommen? Das ist sehr wichtig für mich.
Machen Sie keine Sorge. Sie sind hier. Natürlich werde ich Ihnen einen Krankschreiben oder nach dem Gespräch und nach dem Befunden eine Arbeitumfähigkeit verschreiben.
Keine Sorge. Sie sind jetzt im Krankenhaus.
Auch die letzten drei Tage?
Die letzten drei Tage kann ich leider nicht verschreiben. Für die letzten drei Tage sollen Sie mit Ihrem Hausarzt sprechen.
Okay, das mache ich.
Und weitere Tage kann ich das machen. Ich werde das auch machen. Aber die vorherigen Tage kann ich leider nicht helfen.
Herr Just, sind Sie verheiratet?
Herr Doktor, ja, ich bin verheiratet.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Nein, Herr Doktor.
Nein.
Ich habe eine homosexuelle Beziehung. Aber ich habe eine Adoptierte Tochter.
Eine Adoptierte Tochter, okay.
Okay, Herr Just, ich bin mit meinen Fragen schon fertig. Haben Sie noch Fragen?
Danke, Herr Doktor. Soll ich hierbleiben?
Ja, Sie sollen nach dem Labumatoseuch hierbleiben.
Was machen Sie für mich?
Ich habe den Verdacht auf eine Lungenentzündung. Aber das ist nur eine Vermutung.
Ich werde einen Körper-Untersuchung durchführen. Dann brauchen wir noch eine Blutlabor.
Dann vielleicht einen Röntgen-Torax. Röntgenbrust. Und dann können wir wieder darüber sprechen.
Ist das gefährlich?
Nein, nein, nein. Denken Sie so nicht, bitte.
Nein, ich meine die Röntgen. Sie haben gesagt Röntgen.
Röntgen?
Ja, ich habe Angst vor Strahlen.
Gibt es da einen Röntgenbild, sehr sehr wenig Strahlen. Deswegen brauchen Sie keine Sorge machen.
Einmal ein Röntgen nicht gefährlich.
Danke für diese Erklärung. Ich warte auf Sie, Herr Doktor.
Okay, das war es, Frau Obersten.
Vielen Dank für das Gespräch. Möchten Sie sofort die Vorstellung anfangen?
Ja, bitte.
Ja, hallo, Sie wollen?
Guten Tag, ich bin Frau Müller.
Frau Hansen Natriumwert ist 125 Millimol pro Liter.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihre Oberarztin weiterleiten?
Ja, natürlich.
Danke sehr, schönen Tag.
Danke, ciao.
Frau Hansen Natriumwert.
Herzlich willkommen, Herr Özüvalı. Woher kommen Sie?
Ich komme aus der Türkei.
Seit wann sind Sie in Deutschland?
Seit drei Jahren bin ich in Deutschland.
Was haben Sie bisher in Deutschland gemacht?
Drei Jahre sind nicht so kurz.
Ja, drei Jahre sind sehr sehr lange Zeit.
Ich habe alle Durchkurs in Deutschland gemacht.
B1, Integration nach B2, noch ein PSP und noch dreimalige Hospitation.
Und dann bin ich hier.
Welche Fachrichtungen haben Sie in die Hospitation gemacht und wie lange?
Ja, drei Monate bei der Gastroenterologie und drei Monate bei der Urologie.
Deswegen meine Fachbranche und ein Monat in der Allgemeinen Schürge.
Haben Sie etwas unterschiedliches zwischen Deutschland und dem Türkei Gesundheitssystem bemerkt?
Ja, es gibt sehr große Unterschiede zwischen Deutschland und der Türkei.
Was ist die große Unterschiede?
Bei uns ist das System, stattlich zu dem Versicherungssystem, sehr sehr schnell.
Aber in Deutschland sehr langsam.
Wir haben so viele Patienten, aber Deutschland haben so wenige.
Bei uns ist es möglich, so schnell Termin vereinbaren.
Aber bei uns ist es sehr sehr schwierig.
Bei uns ist das Versicherungssystem für die ganze Stadt, aber in Deutschland privat.
Was gefällt Ihnen? Die Türkei Gesundheitssystem oder Deutschland Gesundheitssystem?
Das kann ich nicht sagen.
Warum sind Sie in Deutschland gekommen?
Das ist eine ungewollte Verfilmung.
Das ist ein ganz politischer Grund, das ist nicht gewollt einzuwandern.
Okay, ich verstehe. Was haben Sie heute für uns?
Herr Obaz, ich habe noch einen neuen Patient.
Es geht um Herrn Tim Nyescht, 38 Jahre, geboren am 04.04.1986.
Haben Sie noch andere Informationen für mich?
Ja, bevor ich meine Patienten vorstelle, möchte ich Ihnen etwas wichtiges mitteilen.
Gerade habe ich aus dem Labor einen Anruf bekommen.
Frau Hansen, die Natriumwerte sind 125.
Was ist Einheit? 125?
Das ist ein minimaler Proliter.
Das ist deutlich erniedrigt.
Das entspricht der Hypo-Natrium.
Was ist die Ursache für die Hypo-Natrium?
Die Ursache für die Hypo-Natrium ist die Diuretik, Herzinfuzions, Lebersrose, Erbrechen, Durchfall und übermäßige Füßigkeit.
Welche Symptome erwarten Sie bei der Hypo-Natrium?
Wir erwarten als Symptome am Anfang Übelkeit, Erbrechen, Kopfschmerzen, Bewusstseinförderung, Krampenfälle und Bewusstseinstörungen bis Koma.
Wie können Sie diese behandeln?
Wir geben als erste Maßnahme das Serum Natrium und behandeln einfach Ursachen.
Füßigkeitsrestriktion und Hyperosmolar-Füßigkeit geben.
Was meinen Sie Hyperosmolar?
Hyperosmolar über 0,9 Osmolar Füßigkeit mit Ion oder Natriumchlorid.
Worauf achten Sie bei der Therapie?
Die Therapie muss immer sehr langsam sein.
Warum?
Wegen einem ungewaltigen Hirnödem.
Nicht Hirnödem?
Warum?
Nicht Hirnödem, keine Hirnödem erwarten wir bei Hypo-Natrium.
Bei Hypo-Natrium erwarten wir schnell Natrium-Schpiegel-Korrigation an Hirnödem.
Aber bei Hypo-Natrium erwarten wir zentrale Pontymian-Lise.
Ja, ja, ja, die Demian-Lise, Pontymian-Slide.
Okay. Was haben wir noch für uns heute?
Ja, ich habe einen neuen Patienten.
Es geht um Tim Jaest.
Tim Jaest stellt sich heute bei uns wegen sechs Tagen.
Soll ich wieder Tim Jaest vorstellen?
Ja, natürlich.
Tim Jaest ist 38 Jahre alt, geboren am 8.04.1986.
1,73 Meter groß und 80 Kilo.
Es geht um Tim Jaest, der stellt sich heute bei uns wegen sechst Tagen bestehende Hüsten vor.
Laut Angaben des Patienten ist der Hüsten mit gelblich und grünem Auswurf, aber ohne Blutung.
Er bietet, dass er seit drei Tagen Brustschmerzen hat.
Nach Angaben des Patienten sind die Schmerzen langsam aufgetreten und jetzt persistierend und sichend.
Die Beschwerden verschleppen sich im Liegen, während sie sich im Sitzen oder stehen besen.
Die Schmerzen strahlen nicht aus. Die Schmerzintensität liegt bei sechs von zehn auf einer Schmerzskala.
Begleitend klagt er seit drei Tagen über eine Düstnung und Fieber.
Seit gestern ist die Körpertemperatur 38,7 Grad Celsius gemessen.
Außerdem bietet er seine Tochter seit einer Woche, vor einer Woche, ähnliche Beschwerden.
Zu Hause hatte er einen Covid-19-Schnelltest durchgeführt.
Das war eine negative Erkrankung.
Bei der Vorerkrankung erwähnte er seit drei Jahren eine arteriöre Hypertonin.
Dagegen nimmt er 5 Milligramm Ramipril täglich.
Bei der Voroperation ergaben sich mit elf Monaten eine Oschiopepsi durchgeführt.
Mit fünf Monaten wurde eine Appendiktomie durchgeführt.
Ich habe gerade gesagt, er nimmt täglich 5 Milligramm Ramipril.
Er ist nicht rauchen.
Akkoholkonsum als Eingläserwein pro Woche wurde beherrt.
Drogenkonsum leider nicht gefragt.
Er hat eine Novalgenallergie, die sich in enge Gefühle äußert.
Bei der Familienanalyse ergab sich, der Vater ist an Lungenkrebs verstorben.
Die Mutter leidet an Morbus Parkinson.
Er ist ein Tischlameister.
Entschuldigung, leidet er unter Apathitlosigkeit oder Gewichtsabnahme?
Ja, ich habe die Übernahme vergessen.
Seit drei Tagen hat er Apathitlosigkeit und Fieber wegen der Schmerzen und Schlafstörungen.
Ich möchte nur hören, ob er Apathitlosigkeit und Gewichtsabnahme hat.
Gewichtsabnahme habe ich nicht gehört.
Ich habe keine Wahrheit über die Gewichtsabnahme.
Diese Information ist sehr wichtig.
Deswegen sollen Sie bei der Körperlehruntersuchung diese Frage stellen.
Warum ist das wichtig?
Gewichtsabnahme.
Bei diesem Patienten, zum Beispiel eine Herzkrankheit oder Luftnot, eine Lungenödema oder ...
Er klagt über Hüsten mit gründlichem Auswurf und Brustschmerzen.
Er hat Lungenprobleme.
Sein Vater und sein Opa sind an Lungenkrebs verstorben.
Nein, nur Vater.
Vater ist an Lungenkrebs verstorben.
Er ist auch Tischlameister.
Deswegen hat er viele Risikofaktoren für Lungenkrebs.
Deswegen ist es wichtig, bei diesem Fall, ob er B-Symptomatik hat.
Gewichtsabnahme ist wichtig.
Danke für diese Information.
Sehr wichtig.
Gewichtsabnahme.
Ich möchte diese Information nicht beantragen.
Zum Ende hat er eine Adoptiertochter.
Ich habe einen Verdacht auf Pneumonie.
Er hat eine produktive Hüste, sich und den Brustschmerzen, Fieber, Müdigkeit, Schlafstörungen und Inappetanz.
Er hat eine Diagnostik von Akutkornensyndrom und Lungenkrebs.
Als Inizial, werde ich als erstes die Körperscheinung durchführen.
Ich werde die Viterparameter messen.
Dann werde ich einen EKG schreiben.
Ich werde die zwei Ebenen an der Kante entfernen.
Blut für das Labor abnehmen.
Blutbild, Leber und Nierenmärte, Inzidenzparameter, Blutgasanalyse, Herzensüme bestimmen lassen.
Und noch eine Sputumkultur.
Meine
und meine
Therapie.
Als Inizial würde ich gerne diese Patienten ambulant behandeln.
Als erste Maßnahme Infusion Therapie, Müffeligkeit und Physikalsuffen und Elektrolytessubstitution.
Und noch Anarchie und Antipirätik.
Welche Anarchie würden Sie den Patienten geben?
Ich empfehle für diese Patienten Paracetamol.
Anarchie und Antipirätik wegen Normalgine Allergie.
Der Patient hat eine Normalgine Allergie.
Er reagiert auf Engelgefühl.
Anarchie und Antipirätik.
Antimikrotik empfehle ich.
Wenn es benötigt ist Sauerstoffgabe.
Wenn die Sauerstoffsetzungen unter Null sind.
Ich empfehle.
Und auf jeden Fall empfehle ich für diese Patienten Betrug.
Gegenfalls eine Antibiotik verschlagen können.
Als erste amperische Optionen Amoxicillin und Chlalazol.
Ich empfehle die Anarchie und Antibiotik.
Danke.
Ekrem, ich habe noch eine Frage für dich.
Aber ich glaube, wir haben schon etwas gesprochen.
Deswegen sage ich es nicht extra.
Du hast heute nur ein paar Aleskut.
Wie viele hast du gestern gesucht?
Ich habe nicht gesucht.
Es waren so viele.
Es gab nur ein paar.
Vorhin waren es nur ein paar.
Es ist besser zu sagen, dass es okay ist.
Okay ist auch gefährlich.
Als Aleskut ist es besser zu sagen, dass es gut ist.
Ich sage es für die Leute.
Sie sagen immer, dass sie wundern.
Aber das ist nicht so.
Wenn ihr in den Krankenhaus geht, dann lacht ihr.
Ich bin ein paar Mal geimpft.
Ich war sehr wütend.
Ich habe mich gefragt, ob ich wütend war.
Er sagte, dass ich wütend war.
Ich habe mich ein paar Mal verbreitet.
Ich habe mich selbst verbreitet.
Es sollte eine Beziehung geben.
Wenn du eine schwierige Situation hast,
dann ist es nicht gut, wütend zu sein.
Wenn du das erste Mal verbreitet hast,
dann ist es nicht gut.
Man muss sich nicht auf die anderen Leute ausüben.
Ich habe auch andere Freunde,
aber es ist nicht nötig, wütend zu sein.
Okay, Chetin, bitte.
Du hattest heute die Fondestellung.
Ich wollte etwas sagen.
Können wir das Original von Bakan als Sadik sagen?
Oder kann ich das Original von Bakan als Fertigkeitskrankung sagen?
Du kannst das Original von Bakan als Fertigkeitskrankung sagen.
Weil du nicht selbst die Sachen des Patienten verwendest.
Ja, das stimmt.
Und ich konnte das Arthralkrankung nicht sagen.
Okay, Chetin.
Das Kilo war sehr schön.
Das war sehr schön, Chetin.
Also ich kann das nicht machen.
Ich bin so ein Nationalspezialist.
Okay, ich habe keine Zigarre.
Aber das Kilo war sehr schön.
Das Kilo war sehr schön.
Du merkst es, wenn man es tut.
Dann fragst du es.
Du musst nicht Angst haben.
Bitte, Chetin.
Guten Tag.
Heute habe ich einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen.
Ich gehe über den Fall meines Patienten. Darf ich vorstellen?
Ja, natürlich. Bitte schön.
Es geht um Tim Yelcht. Er ist 39 Jahre alt, geboren am 08.04.1986.
Er ist 1,73 Meter groß und wiegt 80 Kilo.
Er kommt zu uns heute wegen sechstagen bestehender Hüsten.
Laut Angaben des Patienten ist der Hüsten produktiv mit gelblichem und gründlichem Sputum.
Er berichtet, dass er seit drei Tagen Brustschmerzen hat.
Nach Angaben des Patienten sind die Schmerzen langsam aufgetreten, persistierend, progredient sowie ziehend und stechend.
Er erwähnt, dass die Schmerzen nicht ausstrahlen und die Schmerzintensität liegt bei 6 von 10 auf der NRS.
Die Schmerzen verschlimmen sich im Ligen, während sie sich im Sitzen und Stechen besser stechen.
Begleitend klagt er seit drei Tagen über eine Bewegungsunabhängige Dyspne sowie über Fieber bis 38,7 Grad.
Er berichtet, dass seine Tochter vor einer Woche ähnliche Beschwerden hatte.
Sie ist inzwischen wieder gesund.
Ein Covid-19-Test wurde durchgeführt und war negativ.
Vegetative-Anamnestisch ergaben sich in Somnia ein gewollter Gewichtsverlust von 4 Kilo in drei Monaten, Müdigkeit und Inapetens.
Ansonsten ist die vegetative Anamnese unaufwendig.
An dieser Krankung leidet er seit drei Jahren eine arterielle Hypertonie.
Die Anoperationen sind mit elf Monaten eine Orchidopeksi und mit 15 Jahren eine Appendektomie bekannt.
Der Patient nimmt regelmäßig 5 Milligramm Ramell ein.
Er hat eine Novalgine-Allergie, die sich durch enge Gefühle äußert.
Er trinkt lediglich ein Glas Rotwein pro Woche.
Die Familienanamnese ergab ein Braunschel-Karzinom bei der Mutter.
Er ist auch ein Tischlermeister.
Er ist verheiratet und lebt in einer homosexuellen Beziehung.
Er hat eine adoptierte Tochter.
Nach den anamnestischen Angaben habe ich den Verdacht auf eine Phenomonie.
Dafür sprechen Dyspne, produktive Hüsten, sehende und stöschende Brustschmerzen, Fieber, Müdigkeit sowie eine ähnliche Erkrankung der Tochter vor einer Woche in seiner Umgebung.
Die Differenzialdiagnostik der Braunschelkarzinom und Braunschitis ist in Betracht.
Um meine Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen, werde ich zunächst eine körperliche Untersuchung durchführen.
Bei der Oskultation achte ich auf feuchten Raselgeräuschen.
Anschließend werde ich Vitalparameter überwachen, ein EKG schreiben und um Herzrhythmusstörungen auszuschließen und Blut für das Labor abnehmen.
Im Labor würde ich Blutbild, Entzündungsparameter, Blutgasanalyse, Elektrolyten, Nieren- und Leberwerte bestimmen lassen.
Zusätzlich würde ich eine Sputumkultur veranlassen.
Anschließend werde ich eine Rundgangsthorax in zwei Ebenen veranlassen, gegebenenfalls ein CT-Thorax und bei Bedarf ein pneumologisches Konsil anfordern.
Wenn sich die Verdachtdiagnose bestätigt, kann der Patient zunächst ambulant behandelt werden.
Je nach Befunden ist doch eine stationäre Aufnahme erwägt.
Erforderlich sein.
Der Patient sollte eine Infusiontherapie, Flüssigkeitszufuhr- und Elektrolytsubstitution, sowie eine symptomatische Behandlung mit Analgetikum, Antipirätikum, einem Mukulitikum und Sauerstoffgabe,
durch Nasensonde, wenn die Sauerstoffsättigung unter 92% ist erhalten.
Ich empfehle den Patienten eine Betrugung.
Je nach Kulturergebnis kann ich die Antibiotika verwechseln.
Sie meinen, bevor die Kulturergebnisse, fangen Sie eine Kalkulierte Antibiotika-Therapie an?
Ja, als Empirisch, dann je nach Kulturergebnisse.
Zuerst als Empirisch.
In Deutschland habe ich gehört, statt Empirisch sagen Sie als Kalkulierte Therapie.
Kalkulierte.
Als Kalkulierte Therapie fange ich eine Antibiotika, Amoxicillin, Chlolan, Säure an.
Je nach Befunden der Sputkultur kann Antibiotika geändert werden.
Kalkulierte.
Mit K.
Ja, Kalkulierte.
Sie haben sehr gut vorgestellt.
Ich habe schon fest wie Sie immer vorgestellt.
Ihre Vorstellung ist ähnlich, wie ich früher vorgestellt habe.
Ich habe andere Vorstellungen gesehen, aber ich habe ihre Vorstellungen geändert.
Weil es praktisch oder kompakt ist.
Das ist sehr einfach und deswegen benutze ich diese Vorstellungen.
Man kann einfach für alle Patienten anpassen.
Ja, das ist sehr wichtig für mich.
Ein Schlüssel anpassen für fast alle Fälle.
Sie haben sehr gut vorgestellt.
Okay, dann.
Jetzt die Fragen über den Pneumatis-Kranken.
Wie habe ich es gemacht?
Wir können darüber sprechen.
Und wir können die Reaktionen sprechen.
Pneumatis-Kranken ist generell mit Houston und Auswurf.
Hier kann man auch alle die Fähigkeiten sagen.
Wenn man nicht sagt, dann sagt der Patient etwas.
Wenn der Patient etwas sagt, dann zeigt er, was er sagt.
Das tut mir leid, dass ich das nicht gemacht habe.
Houston und Auswurf.
Wenn er nicht sagt, dann sagt der Patient Auswurf.
Oder der Patient auswurf.
Wie ist das Auswurf?
Gibt es Blut im Auswurf?
Dann die Frage um Houston.
Houston hat hier schon mal Ekrem abe Schittark gefragt.
Aber es gibt keine Frage um Houston.
Daher hat er die Frage gefragt, aber als er die Frage um Houston ansprach,
wäre es besser, das zu fragen.
Ist Houston da, oder ist Houston auf der Atak?
Diese Frage ist wichtig.
Du hast viele Krankheiten als Anfang ausgesucht.
Houston, die mit Atak ausgesucht ist.
In Pneumatis-Kranken ist es nicht in Atak-System.
Es gibt immer noch Körbungen, aber immer noch eine Öksur.
Wenn man in Atak-System ist, ist es ein sehr langweiliges Lufthot.
Dann wird es normal.
Hier wird es immer wieder ausgesucht.
Es gibt immer noch solche Situationen.
Daher ist es besser, Houston zu fragen.
Ich kann Houston fragen.
Ich werde die Frage um mich anschauen, welche Frage ich mir an die Atak-System geben kann.
Hier ist es nicht notwendig, dass man sich einen Frage über die Atak-System geben kann.
Houston hat sechs Tage und die Atak-Systeme drei.
Sie hat ihre Tochter deswegen ihrem Hausarzt besucht und würde ihr eine Diagnose festgestellt.
Ich habe hier auch Fiba gefragt.
Das ist nicht in der Begründung der Anamnesie.
Fiba, Temperaturgemesse,
wie auch Fiba.
Fiba, Schützelfrost, Nachschweiß, Kaltschweiß,
oder Schweißausbrüche.
Das habe ich hier gefragt.
Hier könnt ihr auch das beantworten.
Natürlich.
Hier hat Ferhat gesagt, dass Schinaltest negativ ist.
Das ist schon negativ.
Und da gibt es eine Reaktion.
Ich frage, ob ich Covid-19 kann.
Du musst eine Reaktion geben.
Ja, leider ist das nicht 100% negativ.
Aber keine Sorge.
Wir werden hier wieder einen Test machen.
Wir werden einen anderen Test machen.
Und wir werden ihn ausdrücken.
Wir werden den Patienten nicht verändern,
wenn er negativ ist.
Wir werden keine Tätigkeiten verändern.
Nur um zu zeigen, wie man es weiß.
Ich kenne diese Atmosphäre.
Ich kenne die Anamnesie.
Auf der anderen Seite habe ich Fiba und alles,
Dann die Gevichte, Inapathens, Schlaffstörungen, die hier.
Schaut mal, die B-Symptomatik hier ist wichtig.
Am Anfang versteht man nicht, dass die B-Symptomatik wichtig ist,
aber danach gibt es in der Anamnesie Broncher-Carsinom,
dann Tichelmeistabon, Bizzikofaktoren.
Deswegen ist die B-Symptomatik wichtig.
Gevichte, Inapathens, wir vergessen sie.
Und wir fragen sie hier.
Wir müssen sie alle Patienten auch fragen.
Und um sie nicht zu vergessen, haben wir hier eine Schema um die Vagatat von Anamnesen.
Fibachitil, Froznachschwach, Casvachschwach, Ausbrühe,
dann Inapathens, Gevichte, Schlaffstörungen,
dann die Herz- und Lungen-Aufschmerzen, Nufnod, Engageful, Herzrasen.
Aber wo habe ich sie schon gefragt?
Ich habe sie auch in der Abbechwerde gefragt.
Dann habe ich die Gastrointestin,
Übigkeit, Erbrechen, Stürgang-Probleme, Vasalasen-Probleme.
Ich habe sie alle gefragt.
Dann habe ich sie immer wieder gefragt.
Die Reaktionen bei diesem Patienten...
Die Reaktion, die ich erinnere, ist,
dass sie einen Covid-19-Test machen.
Dort fragt sie, ob sie das nicht tun,
wenn sie das nicht tun.
Ich freue mich, zu hören,
dass ihr Schnelltest negativ war.
Aber das ist nicht unbedingt...
Das ist nicht unbedingt der Niveau, aber...
Der Schnell-Covid-19-Test ist nicht immer...
Aber das ist nicht unbedingt sicher.
Aber Sie müssen sich nicht versorgen,
wir werden hier noch andere Tests durchführen,
um Covid-19 auszuschließen.
So etwas habe ich gesagt.
Schnelltest ist nicht 100% sicher.
Es ist nicht sicher.
Aber Sie müssen sich nicht versorgen,
wir werden hier noch andere Tests durchführen,
um es auszuschließen.
Dann gibt es noch eine Reaktion.
Das ist um den Schnelltest.
Das ist 11 Monate,
bis es dann wieder auslöscht.
Das ist die Frage, ob es notwendig ist.
Da hat Ekrem sehr gut verantwortlich gesagt.
Die Hoden befinden sich im Bauch.
Nach dem Geburt sollen sie in den Hodenstock absteigen.
Wenn nicht, sollte eine Operation durchgeführt werden,
um ein paar Gefahr zu vermeiden.
Zum Beispiel Hodenkrebs oder Unfurchtbarkeit
oder Hoden-Torsion.
Dann kann ich sagen, dass es hier noch eine Reaktion gibt.
Wenn nicht, sollte eine Operation durchgeführt werden,
um ein paar Gefahr zu vermeiden.
Das ist die Reaktion, die ich vorhin gemacht habe.
Dann kann ich sagen, dass es hier noch eine Reaktion gibt.
Ich habe keine Angst, weil ihre Vater und ihre Opa an Lungenkrebs verletzt sind.
Ich kenne sie nicht, weil sie ...
Man kann es so sagen.
Ich kenne sie nicht, weil ihre Vater und ihre Opa an Lungenkrebs verletzt sind.
Ich kenne sie nicht, weil ihre Opa an Lungenkrebs verletzt sind.
...
Man kann sie nicht, weil ihre Opa an Lungenkrebs verletzt sind.
Aber das kann man auch sagen.
Dieser Patient hat eine Gewichtabnahme, aber eine Gewaltgewichtabnahme.
Dieser Mann machte eine Wasa-Diät oder eine andere Diät.
Er hat alles verändert.
Aber das ist Gewalt.
Er hat nur Wasa getrunken, seit ein paar Monaten.
Deswegen hat er 3-4 Kilo Milch verloren.
Da wird eine Reaktion vorgelegt.
Er sagt, dass er eine Wasa-Diät macht.
Wasa-Diät oder Wasa-Diät und Fallen.
Das ist ein Beispiel, um zu sagen, dass er das nicht macht.
Wenn ich das Internet finde,
Ich verstehe, dass Sie Gewicht abnehmen möchten.
Aber unser Körper braucht Energie oder Nahrstoff.
Deswegen kann das gefährlich sein.
Aber wenn Sie möchten, kann ich Ihnen gerne eine Diät-Assistentin empfehlen.
So etwas kann gesagt werden.
Wenn wir zwischen ein Kanzler und ein Schleiferschein oder ein Schleiferschein
in der Natur bleiben müssen,
kann das Abklarin-Gesetz sein.
Und das Absklarin.
Ja, das ist besser.
Abklarin.
Und das Absklarin.
Dr. Chetin, dann nenne ich eine ganze Sitzung.
In der Frage, ob das Absklarin ist,
nenne ich die Sitzung.
Okay.
Wir werden alle notwendige Unterzufrucht führen, um das Absklarin.
Okay, danke.
Sümera, kann ich ein paar Sätze sagen?
Ja.
Heute, Herr Ekrem,
also,
zum Beispiel,
das Covid-Test, das ist ein schönes Beispiel.
Ich habe es immer vergessen, in diesem Fall.
Und Sie sahen sich auch als Doktor an?
Als die Zeit umgekehrt hat,
bis wo? Bis zum Allergie.
Heute, also,
es gibt ein bisschen Geschwindigkeit.
Wenn ich das so nenne,
dann weiß ich, was da passiert.
Das ist mir sehr erinnernd.
Danke.
Dr. Chetin, du hast die Doktorin sehr gut gehört.
Das verstehe ich.
Ich?
Dr. Chetin, du hast die Doktorin sehr gut gehört.
Sie hat die Sorge gesagt.
Sie hat nichts verpasst.
Und wenn sie nicht eine Antwort darauf hat,
oder wenn sie etwas anderes...
Ich wollte das fragen.
Und dann...
Er hat diese Konsequenzen in der Details erzählt.
Er hat gesagt, dass er dort Zeit verdient und sie sich auch interessiert.
Aber natürlich kann das von der Person, die vor ihm vorliegt, verändern.
Ich habe in meiner eigenen Forderung nicht die Details in die Details gewünscht.
Ich habe mir gefragt, wie ich Zeit von anderen Menschen verdienen kann.
Yoko, wenn Sie so viel Information aufgeben, natürlich.
Aber ich schaue mir die Noten an, was es gibt.
Ich habe eine Erklärung von PCR.
Das ist eine lange, lange Zeit.
Es ist keine kurze Sitzung.
Ich habe da keine Erklärung gemacht.
Ich habe es gerade gesagt, wenn ich an der Arbeit arbeite.
Ich werde einen anderen Test machen.
Wenn der Patient mich fragt, welchen Test ich machen soll,
dann sagt er, dass es PCR ist.
Ich habe das gedacht.
Ich sage nur, dass Polymer, Ketan, Reaktion, so viel.
Ich habe es sehr gut verstanden, wenn der Patient die Reaktion von Polymer, Ketan sagt.
Ich werde nicht sagen, wenn der Patient das sagt.
Wenn der Patient das sagt, kann ich es nicht erklären.
Wie kann ich das erklären? Polymer, Ketan, Reaktion, Patient.
Ich habe das auch gedacht.
Das kann nicht unbedingt sein.
Ich hoffe es.
Ich schalte die Aufnahme an.